I mean everything is going to be
digitized and that is just the way of
the future and a lot of old school
people in the business are complaining
about it but you know I only see it it
can only be like a positive thing I mean
I know people already who are
downloading books on the ipad and i have
one myself I'm not downloading books on
the ipad because i like holding books
still because I'm old and I'm from the
Empire the old world and i just used to
reading books that way and I'm not yet
you know moved into the ipad world but
you know i did get an ipad because a
friend of mine showed me his ipad and
how he was reading books on it and how
he bought more books once he had the
ipad then he had ever bought that last
six months on amazon or going to a to a
bookstore and also the you know the idea
of a book costing not $25 anymore but
ten bucks means you're also wiping away
a lot of the cost of making a book you
know the printing the shipping etc etc
and so and so the royalty rates for
authors are shifting as well so it's not
as if others are necessarily going to
lose money on on their work in terms of
people like buying to download them it
the royalty rate is actually to be about
the same if not more because we're
cutting out all those other costs so
that can be a good thing as well but you
know from of but it's it's we just kind
of see where it's going i think we're in
a transitional moment now in the
publishing industry a lot of people are
very worried and they don't kind of get
what's going to happen and i think they
just need to like get with it a little
bit more and not be so scared i mean but
i do think that there is a problem right
now with people reading fiction we
haven't gotten to that point where it
looks so good on though it does look
really good on the ipad though i don't
have enough people know about this where
we it looks so good on digitally
rendered that it's worth doing you know
i think people are still a little
nervous about that
I think people started writing
differently once computers came into
play I think people started writing
differently I noticed a difference in
books when people were writing books on
computers and not composing them long
hand and not doing them on typewriters
but books seemed longer and they seemed
more extravagant and decorative and you
know um once you could start doing
footnotes and books all uh David Foster
Wallace or you know Dave Eggers or you
know whoever I mean and and or I think
of uh a book like house of leaves by
part mark Daniel s key in terms of how
it's designed or is his follow-up only
revolutions I mean yes I saw big
difference in books by people my age
because of the computer now in terms of
books becoming you know digitized I
don't know I mean if we're going to make
yet I mean I guess the next step is when
I was looking at my friend's ipad i mean
and i was looking through a novel there
was you know a way to UM if you wanted
to find out something about a certain
historical figure or the genesis of a
certain word you could like you know
find that out while you're reading the
text or you could remove that and not
have that be part of reading experience
but you can't have that and that might
be you know another part of how we read
books then I mean it just might be the
next step in how we experience fiction
but I don't look at it as a negative
thing you know I can't you you just sort
of have to like you know move along with
a culture and see where it goes and it
could end up being someplace you know
very cool and I think that's really
exciting and I think actually when I
look at a lot of fiction now and how
dreary a lot of it is and i spec and
also not only how dreary a lot of it is
but also I think our collective
impatience with fiction like just
holding a book that's just full of words
about a you know a made-up situation
made up characters I mean I think we now
live in a society where we want more
more of that what you're talking about
more of an interactive experience we
want to see images we want to see you
know
a lot more of a light show or something
that makes sense to me and I think
that's that can be incredibly exciting
so once that really does start happening
um I don't know that could even possibly
you know reenergize my faith in in
fiction
fected a huge amount by that because um
because of all these distractions um I
look um a lot of my friends college
educated smart people adults who used to
read a lot of fiction have admitted to
me that technology has disrupted their
patients with fiction and there's so
many other things going on that once uh
you know that what I mean if none of
this stuff was available to them whether
it's you know checking their Facebook
page or you know reading articles online
and then linking to an the next article
in the next article the next article
that they might be sitting down with a
novel instead I think this is I think
all the time that we spend with
technology has definitely cut into the
idea of you know that that kind of
active uh the the active I don't know
the active active you know reading a
novel where you are sitting there and
you're reading the book and you're
creating the world in your mind and its
really the ultimate virtual reality show
with you reading a novel because you're
in complete control of how the rooms
look at how the characters look and you
know I think that that experience of
being alone with the book has been in a
way degraded by technology and it's been
you know it's just it's just something
that's happened